[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Marci Shore an associate professor of
history at Yale she researches and
teaches European cultural and
intellectual history and is the
award-winning author of caviar and ashes
and the taste of ashes today we'll talk
with Professor shor about her latest
book the ukrainian night in intimate
history of revolution welcome professor
sure thank you for having me so it's
lovely to have you back I remember a few
years ago you were on talking about I
think it was your first book the taste
of a perspective the second book yes so
that was very interesting and now we're
going to talk about your newest book so
let's give us an overview of it okay my
newest book or most recent book the
Ukrainian night is a book about the
Ukrainian revolution on the Maidan that
happened in 2013 and 2014 and the short
version of a long and complicated story
about that revolution is that in Ukraine
is a post-soviet country against its
independence in 1991 there is followed a
kind of rough post-soviet highly corrupt
oligarchical transition in 2004 there is
a presidential election between Viktor
Yanukovych who is somewhat kind of the
gangster type president closely aligned
with Russia and Viktor Yushchenko who
seems to be looking towards Europe as a
result of both election fraud and an
attempt to poison youth Jenko with
dioxin Yanukovych is declared the winner
at that point people go onto the streets
for three weeks they go on to the big
main square in the center of Kiev called
the Maidan and they protest and they
demand for elections
and somewhat miraculously they are
successful with no violence with no
fighting the elections are held again
this time use Jenko is declared the
winner everybody is happy and goes home
it seems that Viktor Yanukovych can
never come back but then what happens
for a short version of a long story is
that use Jenko turns out to be a
disappointment perhaps for
overdetermined reasons
Yanukovych whom everybody thought could
not possibly come back hires a public
relations specialist a fancy public
relations specialist from Washington who
has a little boutique industry doing
public relations for gangster types with
presidential ambitions so this man whose
name as it turns out is Paul Manafort
goes over to Kiev not knowing Russia and
not knowing Ukrainian and gives
Yanukovych a makeover in my opinion it
wasn't terribly effective he still
struck me as a gangster but he comes
back this time legitimately to win the
2010 elections in Ukraine and at that
point there is a feeling of resignation
but there's also a feeling that despite
everything at the very least Yanukovych
is nominally leading Ukraine towards
eventual European Union integration in
2013 who's due to sign an association
agreement on behalf of Ukraine with the
European Union now it was not a
fantastic agreement it would have
involved Ukraine undertaking costly
reforms it likely would have provoked
retaliation from Russia and at the end
of the day it promised no eventual
membership in the European Union
nonetheless it was a foot in the door it
was a step in that direction it was a
sign that Ukraine was moving towards the
West was moving towards Europe was
moving outside of its Soviet legacy and
then suddenly at the eleventh hour when
the signing ceremony in Vilnius was
already prepared on November 21st 2013
Yanukovych suddenly says he's not going
to sign it and at that point there
they're shocked and a sense of despair
especially among young people and
especially among students who had the
most to lose they were the ones for whom
the question of whether or not Europe
was open to them meant the most would
they be able to study abroad would they
learn languages you know would they be
eligible for internships in the European
Union would they be able to go to
conferences and to meetings without you
know lengthy expensive humiliating visa
application processes and the students
were the ones you know who were the most
upset I think arguably on November 21st
still nothing might have happened had
not this 32 year old Afghan Ukrainian
journalist named Mustafa nyam posted on
Facebook that day a short little message
in Russian that said hey guys you know
let's be serious
you know if you're really upset come out
to the maidan by midnight tonight the
big square in the center of Kiev and
then he said likes do not count
interestingly that's a sentence that
would have made no sense before Facebook
Likes do not count it would have been
meaningless it becomes a revolutionary
slogan for the 21st century people come
out that night how many a couple hundred
perhaps mostly but not entirely students
young people they held hands they saying
they had music the slogan was Ukraine is
Europe that was it it was not about
language politics it was not about
ethnic politics it was not about
political parties it was just Ukraine is
Europe we are part of Europe and they
continued to be there kind of night and
day for the next nine days or so it was
very cold it was late November Kiev it's
far in the north but it still had a kind
of friendly you know
quasi carnivalesque atmosphere young
people dancing music and that might have
all kind of faded away with time as I
got colder and colder but then on the
night between November 20
November 30th Yanukovych decided to send
out his riot police to brutally beat up
the students and that was unprecedented
really in in post-soviet Ukraine I mean
there was a sense of an unspoken social
contract that the government didn't use
that kind of obvious mass violence
against its own said why did he decide
to do that after a significant time had
passed and they were already you know
seemingly peaceful it's a very
interesting question I suspect but I
can't prove this and I certainly have no
special access to what was going on his
head that he was counting on the fact
that the parents would pull their kids
off the streets if he does something
shocking
not so brutalist to kill them but brutal
enough to seriously injure some of them
that would scare everyone and the
parents would pull the kids back on the
streets but that was when the miracle
happened and that was when it was in
fact that was when I started paying
attention I admittedly hadn't been
paying too much attention because
suddenly he sends out these people but
riot police 4:00 in the morning the
middle of the night he brutally beats up
the students counting on I think the
parents to pull their kids off the
streets and instead of pulling their
kids off the streets the parents join
them there and a day later you have
close to a million people on the streets
of Blau no one had ever seen that many
people on the streets of Kiev I can
imagine so
let's backtrack a little bit why did he
not sign that agreement that's also
unclear I mean the presumption is that
it was pressure from Putin either
threats or pressure or nobody really
knows exactly what was happening in his
mind as some people thought maybe he
meant to sign it later some people
thought he didn't realize the cost were
going to be that high the assumption is
that there was some last-minute pressure
from Putin but why it came at that
moment as opposed to earlier I don't
know okay so in in writing your book how
did you do the research for it well I
should say first of all it's a book I
never planned on writing okay on the
contrary in some sense I specifically
planned not
I'm not writing it I you specifically
plan on I'm writing about contemporary
politics I don't work on contemporary
politics moreover as a historian I don't
trust myself to write in real time if
historians have advantages over
journalists and social sciences they all
come from retrospect right you know what
allows us to play God with that
perspective is looking back yes looking
back you can know more than anyone could
know in real time so I never plan to
write the book I was trying not to write
the book I found myself unable to turn
away at a certain moment I felt like in
all the quarter century or so which is
my whole adult life that I had been
hanging out in Eastern Europe this was
the most extraordinary thing I had ever
seen okay
and I I realized that I realized that
this was not just a political protest
this was an existential transformation
it was the return of metaphysics you
know it was a fundamental kind of break
in time that new human beings were being
forged out there and I also saw and this
is something I understood not because
I'm smarter than other people but I was
in Vienna at the time I was at a
Research Institute that had been created
in the early 80s as a meeting place for
Easter peon and West European
intellectuals I had several close
colleagues from Ukraine who were back
and forth to began all that year I knew
people who were out there it was that
contiguity it was that closeness it
wasn't that I was more perceptive than
other people it was that I was I was
closer to people who were there and I
also saw that it was not understood it
wasn't understood the American press it
wasn't understood in the German press it
wasn't understood in the Austrian press
there was a sense that something
extraordinary was happening that my
Ukrainian friends and colleagues were
enormous ly frustrated that they were
not being taken seriously and they could
not convey this um the poles understood
you know and and one of the things that
startled me was comparing the Polish
press with the German press because an
in Poland it was somehow understood
intuitively you know and in Germany and
Austria wasn't and that's when I thought
well maybe I could play a small
roll as good of the cultural mediator in
the situation like the American Slav
assist who was in the very strange
position of you know sitting in Vienna
and watching them ID on through polish
eyes at a certain sense and I thought
maybe I could play a small role and give
it a human face not kind of not
intervene with political analysis not
tell people what they should do or what
the policy should be or who should put
sanctions on whom but just try to give
it a human face okay so how did you do
that well initially I decided that I
would try to write a portrait of an
individual you know I'm I say I don't
work on contemporary politics and I
don't even work specifically on
political history I work on intellectual
history in the history of ideas so I
thought well the one thing you know I
you know I know something about perhaps
is writing about intellectuals and
revolution how they reflect on it how
they process it you know how they
philosophically work themselves towards
it and I thought well if I could write a
portrait of a person you know and just
try to explain what pushes people to
make choices what pushes someone to make
choices that a few months ago he or she
could not have conceived of himself
making and so I thought well I'll just
I'll focus on one person and I'll try to
make it very granular you know and very
intimate and very human why does
somebody who has so much to lose decide
to risk their life in this way and so I
one of the reasons I thought about doing
a portrait of an intellectual is not
because I think intellectuals are more
important than other people but
intellectuals have the convenient and
very helpful characteristic that they
write you know and so I I had two little
kids at the time I was still
breastfeeding my daughter I thought I
can't take them to this country in the
middle of a revolution I also can't
leave them for very long without me I
had never let left both of them
overnight before I thought I I can go
over quickly I can stay for a day or two
or maybe three and do some long
interviews but what I really need is
somebody with a written record who will
give me some diachronic death you know I
need somebody who has been publishing
for long enough that I have more sources
to work with
and so I strategically then selected a
translator essayist and psychoanalyst
named your GoPro Roscoe who's brilliant
and wonderful also because I knew him
very vaguely we kind of moved in the
same circles but I hadn't known him well
before he grew up kind of trilingual in
Ukrainian native language Russian and
polish
I don't speak Ukrainian I understand a
lot but I don't speak it per se my
Russian was rusty the Polish was a
language I used almost every day and I
knew that yerko had basically native
polish so I thought okay I can go over
there I don't need any like warmup time
you know and I can talk to him right
away and I'll be able to understand
everything right away um and he was a
writer who whose voice I had long I had
long admired who I felt connected to who
I thought I could I could see how I
could use different things he had
published in different languages and
pulled them together in a portrait okay
so there are others though - yes well
what happened was that I you know I
would so I went over to l'viv I talked
to your Co and then a friend of mine
said you know this revolution really
began with the students you know they
were there first
Yoko's nephew who is a young journalism
student and in the son of your COEs
brother who is a very well-known
novelist in ukraine he was one of the
student leaders from the beginning you
should talk to him while you were there
so I talked to your co Ivan talked to
Marquis on his nephew and then of course
once I talked to marking on there was a
temptation talked to mark Ian's father
and then while I was at l'viv you know
another friend said oh you know what
there's a woman you would love to be
she's you know she's a middle-aged real
estate agent she had never been
particularly politically active she's
the one who ended up organizing all the
buses that transported people from l'viv
to Kia's to take part in the revolution
and so my friend all-stop takes me over
to see this real estate agent and as
soon as I started to interview her I
could already as she was talking I could
see how she would work as a kind of
literary character I could already he
was showing me these little notebooks
that were like those children's
notebooks on
on graph paper with the little squares
instead of the lines with the tacky
pictures of like Levi's and you know
flowers on top these kind of little
notebooks that they sell all over Europe
for school kids and in that notebooks
the people who came to get on the buses
and to donate money to send other people
to the my Don
we're like they were handwritten with
like the name of the person you know and
the amount of money they were donating
to keep the records and she's showing me
these little notebooks with the tacky
pictures of the jeans and the coffee and
the graph paper and then she was
explaining you know what it meant to
somehow become a revolutionary organizer
you know having you know spent her life
as as a kind of real estate you know
middle rank real estate agent in a small
city so when you're talking to these
people what was the driving motivator
for them to participate in the
revolution it may have varied I imagine
or maybe not this was the this was the
interesting question for me and this is
where I think that moment of when the
students got beaten up turned because
before that it was all about getting
Ukraine into Europe after that and they
called the students called that protest
movement your own light on after
December first it was just my dawn and
it was no longer just about the European
Union now it was really a revolt you
know against something that in Russian
it's called pure evil and it's an almost
untranslatable word that means
arbitrariness kind of with a tinge of
tyranny the sense that you are a
helpless plaything at the hands of the
powers that be that you are being
treated as an object and not a subject
as a thing and not as a human being in
and after December 1st the Maidan was
really about asserting human dignity in
human subjectivity against the sense
that we are being treated you know as
things you know as playthings to be
disposed of at the whim of the powers
that be you know and it was that like
deep revolt against the assault on human
dig
that philosophically captured me mm-hmm
so what ended up happening with the
Revolution how did it end it ended in a
very bloody way it progressed over time
by the beginning of December it was no
longer just a protest movement it was a
whole parallel polis it was a whole
parallel society so the Maidan which is
of one of the things that's significant
about it is that it's a city square in
the center of a big city it's an
unusually large square which played a
role and also an architectural II
complex space that was kind of on
different levels in its various
different kinds of configurations they
created a whole parallel world there
there were people living in tents there
were medical clinics there were open
universities film screenings whole
kitchens you know people were you know
making tea people were making food there
was clothing distribution people were
living on them I don okay and there was
a whole parallel world there in a sense
a whole parallel world that was
functioning according to the values that
people wanted to see brought forth in
their own society that which were not
and so suddenly you had this coming
together of people who never would have
encountered one another in real life my
my friends loved go hurts like said it
was like a Noah's Ark yeah you had to of
every kind you had parents and children
and workers and intellectuals and people
on the right - people on the left and
people from the countryside and people
from the city and people who normally
never would have found themselves in the
same place and here they were not just
engaging in a protest together but
really living in this alternative world
together okay so how did that come to an
end on the violence increased all
through the winter
I mean Yanukovych progressively used
more and more violence at a certain
point in the middle of January he passed
by an illegal show of hands a vote in
Parliament these what we're called the
dictatorship laws essentially making it
illegal for anyone to
in any way and I think again he thought
by raising the stakes he would push
people to go home but instead what
happened as he raised the stakes so that
people felt it was all or nothing now
anyone could be thrown in prison just
for being there now everyone knew that
nobody was safe until he was gone and
and one of the things that most
fascinating terrified me is that in in
the end of now at the end of November
amid end of November nobody was thinking
they were going to die there that was
not that wasn't that was not in
anybody's head something changed those
last couple weeks in January by the end
of January beginning of February a
critical mass of people were willing to
die there and you could feel it like
even from a distance and you could feel
it almost palpably that they had made a
decision they were not going to leave
and at a certain point you were in this
kind of paralyzed terror waiting to see
how it would end and it ends with the
massacre Wow and how many people were
lost over a hundred people were killed
in the end the then Polish foreign
minister Radek Sikorski together
initially with the French and the German
foreign ministers came over during the
shooting and tried to negotiate a
ceasefire with Yanukovych which was one
of the moments I was very interested in
other prominent Ukrainian figures
including the rock stars love of our car
Chuck who was factor at Yale for a
semester in the world Fellows program he
and some of his colleagues ran over to
Parliament to try to persuade the
parliamentarians during the massacre -
at least symbolically you know passed
some kind of resolution to stop the
shooting there was eventually a
ceasefire negotiated with the Yanukovych
it was very hard to get any
representatives of the Maidan to sign it
and a moment when their people were
being massacred and by snipers you know
so there were people firing from
buildings in the ends Radek Sikorski
managed and it could have extraordinary
film clip that you can find on the
internet to persuade them essentially
drawing on
fact that he was a pole who came of age
during solidarity and he said yeah in
1981
you know we overestimated our strength
and underestimated the government
strength and we got martial law and mass
detentions of all our leaders you know
you guys signed this or you're all going
to be dead mm-hmm and he believed it you
know at the time so eventually they
agreed you know there's a ceasefire
although there's a lot a very strong
feeling that the fact that Yanukovych
for any length of time is going to
remain the president when he has all
this blood on his hands was intolerable
but it ended up being a moot point
because within 24 hours or so he had
fled across the border to Russia okay so
were there any consequences or I should
say I'm sure there were consequences
what were the consequences for the
people who you talk about in your book
the consequences were heavy for everyone
I would say including for ourselves in
this country because Yanukovych flees
across the border to Russia that's
February 2014 Paul Manafort is out of a
job
and we all know what he did next within
days you know the Kremlin was illegally
annexing Crimea and inciting a war in in
the Donbass which continues to this day
a completely grotesque war one of the
people who was killed on the Maidan was
a graduate student to finishing graduate
student young professor named blogged on
sekonic
I I didn't know him personally although
he had come to my husband's seminar
sometimes in Warsaw and we knew many
people in common and then I got to know
a lot of his friends afterwards who were
also the graduate students of my
colleagues in Ukraine and they very much
had this feeling of needing to do
something kind of in his memory there
were many people who who fought you know
who had post-traumatic stress quite
trial and one of the stories I tell in
the book in fact the stories I open the
book with is that
a story of a young man named Misha who
was a student at the time his graduate
student now a very and he's very thin a
little bit nerdy very sweet these
amazing brown eyes very very serious
student you know from a family with no
money in which he is the only man
there's a grandmother a single mother
Misha and his and his much younger
sister whom he helped take care of he
had never done anything that involved
any kind of fighting before and he was
out there during the dürer during the
shooting
yeah and was quite convinced he was
going to be killed but was you know felt
like he had to stay it was a moral
imperative to stay and he ended up
saving somebody else's life there when
he carries this wounded man back
together with a friend and his his
mother is calling him during and
pleading with him to come home and his
grandmother is calling him pleading with
him to come home you know and he says no
I can't I have to stay and he survived
but it was very very hard for him to
calm down afterwards and when I met him
he was still very very shaky with those
dire consequences moving forward and
again this happened 2014-2015 right
that's 2013-2014 okay so that's really
not that long ago at all so I'm
wondering now moving forward here we are
in 2019 almost 2020 what effect has that
revolution had on on Ukraine in terms of
you know people still remember as a very
bloody situation and I can only imagine
it must have a significant effect on the
people I think it changed everybody who
went through it in a very profound way
there's been a widespread sense of
disappointment that the values that were
so strongly expressed and agreed upon
have not found expression in the
political realm to the extent they would
like
there's also sense that they are it is
very difficult to do anything in that
country because this grotesque war
continues right and it's very hard to
even know what the revolution would have
been and what the consequences would
have been had there not been this war
and the war was really one of the things
I described in the book is that the
Madonn for me was a moment of modernism
in the sense of we believed in truth we
believed that there is such thing as a
human subject that is real that sustains
an identity that is endowed with conte
and dignity we believe that there is
such a thing as truth you know we
believe that there's a distinction
between truth and lies that was a kind
of modernist moment when I teach
intellectual history I tell my students
that modernity is all about replacing
God post modernity is when you give up
on replacing God and that border between
modernity and postmodernity happens
right at the end of February 2014 when
the war in the dumb boss begins because
it's literally invented I mean then you
have post truth you know suddenly you
have you know separatist gangster types
rising up on you know overthrowing
governments telling local people that
the Maidan was a cia-sponsored fascist
conspiracy and Ukrainian Nazis with
American weapons are now coming to kill
all the Russian speakers in eastern
Ukraine and nobody even really
understood what was going on in the
beginning one of the stories I tell in
the second half of the book ends up
being largely about the war they don't
last which I hadn't expected but one of
the stories I tell was ultimately by a
young woman from Donetsk in the dumb
boss who had been she was a graduate
student in media study she was one of
the curators of a kind of gallery salon
discussion place called these Latvia and
that space was taken over by the
separatist when they took over Donetsk
it was turned into a prison she and her
friends ended up leaving you know they
went to Kiev and that later maybe a year
or so later several months later sitting
with her this
they in Kiev and she was nit trying to
narrate to me exactly what happened when
the separatists arrived well there were
these guys and I kind of remembered them
from high school they always had these
leanings that there were those guys that
no one really knew who they were but
they were always kind of hooligans and
then their works
you know the people coming across the
border from Russia and saying they were
tourists and she's like and then one day
the Chechens appeared and they didn't
even speak Russian very well and they
didn't understand why they were getting
Ukrainian Kresna instead of Russian
roubles from the bank machines and then
they called this meeting on Lenin square
and an elderly yo Orthodox Christian
grandmother comes to the meeting on
Lenin Square and she gives an Orthodox
christening to the chechen soldier so
that he'll he would be victorious and
battle against the ukrainian nazis and
poor Katja sitting there trying to
explain this to me in Kiev like tearing
her hair out and she's saying you'll
Marcy everything it's everything is
fiction in this story you have that the
Christian grandmother on the communists
square giving an Orthodox christening to
a Muslim soldier so that he can be
victorious in battle against
non-existent Ukrainian Nazis everything
is fiction and it's all really happening
to us wow that isn't that's amazing
amazing so what do you think the future
holds for Ukraine at this point I wish I
knew historians in the best case can
tell you what already happened yes we're
very very bad about telling you what
will happen one thing I can say is that
if I understood maybe faster than some
of my other American friends and
colleagues what was happening here three
years ago three and a half years ago and
continues to this day it's not because I
was smarter but because I understood
what was happening in Russia and Ukraine
right so are you have you changed your
mind and wrote the book that's a good
question so I I wrote the essay and I
meant it as again an intervention almost
as a cultural mediator as a translate
as somebody who was just trying to kind
of help one world understand another
world and I wrote it the summer of 2014
it ended up being longer than I had
intended I I published it in German
which in some sense was my target
audience because I was living in Vienna
and I was surrounded by the German
language press and that was in some
sense the press that my Ukrainian
friends cared about the most many of
them were German estoy training you know
many of the leading Ukrainian
intellectuals were late lectured in
Germany they translated German
literature but there was also a sense
that the EU meant Germany you know that
was that was the audience to whom they
were addressing themselves so the cold
reception from the German speaking press
was particularly painful America was all
the way across the ocean of course we
have no culture were existentially thin
we're never going to understand anything
but for the Germans not to understand
was particularly painful I mean we're
trying to be part of this world and so I
did you know in a very good journal with
a wonderful editor in German in a good
German translation to the extent that my
Germans good enough to judge the
translation I wrote in English and then
I I was unable to find an editor for it
in English or I was unable to find
anyone who would take it at that length
it was a moment where people wanted
Policy Analysis and there was no policy
analysis people wanted something that
was three thousand words and I had
fifteen thousand words and so everyone
was saying well you have to cut it in
two thirds or in half and I showed it to
one editor who was the time at Yale
Steve Wasserman who I knew you know
asking if he could recommend some kind
of venue for it in English and he read
it and he called me and he said Marcy
let's have coffee and then he said you
know you shouldn't cut it you should go
back to Ukraine you should talk to more
people and this should be a short book
and at first I said no I couldn't
possibly do that like I wasn't I wasn't
there when people were shooting I wasn't
there at the right time
I don't speak Ukrainian I don't cover
contemporary things but he kept talking
to me about it
and
the more I thought about it the more I
found myself irrationally drawn into it
feeling like the thing for whatever
irrational reason I have to do at the
moment is write this book right right
well I'm certainly happy that you did
thank you so much for being here and
sharing some of your work well thank you
so much for having me for more
information about Professor Shore and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Centre for International and
area studies at Yale
you